Michael let's focus in on those four
areas that that Alex was talking about
and we can see from the map here that
Russia doesn't completely hold all four
of those territories no it doesn't and
uh it won't stop them claiming it of
course but they're even even in luhansk
which they did occupy pretty well all of
they're now losing some of that
territory and we'll probably lose a bit
more and down in the southwestern
Kirsten again they certainly don't hold
all of that and they're losing more of
that and may lose quite a lot of it in
due course so they're claiming uh will
claim sovereignty over territories that
actually they don't even control if we
look at what's happening on the ground
uh we see the way that the battle is
tending to go because
um the uh the the areas of luhansk
um are present are likely to be
surrounded to the South Donetsk uh the
Russians are pushing back a bit of
Donetsk but they still have a lot of
total that they can't control and it all
comes down in incidentally to a sort of
a fairly key communication life we look
a bit more closely at what's happening
in the uh in the North in the donbass
area the luhansk area the line from
troiska to svatovay to cremina that's
the main road there's no other good
roads there and that's the main
communication lines now the Russians are
digging in it's for Tori and the
ukrainians are pushing quite hard
against it this is the new battle this
is the the area having been pushed out
of uh kharkiv Province this is where the
Russians are now trying to dig in but
the ukrainians are very clear that they
want to break that line because that's
the route to forces further south the
ukrainians are almost now look as if
they're beginning to surround Lyman the
Russians really need to hold Lyman and
they are under great pressure because
the ukrainians are beginning to get
around the back of them so Russia looks
as if they if they can't hold these two
lines Lyman and Satori in particular
they will lose quite a lot of territory
meanwhile the Russians really are
counter-attacking a back mode the Wagner
group The the private military
group that used convicts from the
prisons they've made some
um inroads of bakmut and they've
actually forced ukrainians back over the
river which runs through the middle of
the city but that won't do them much
good even if they take back more they're
going to be outflanked if the ukrainians
are able to move further into luhansk so
that's the the battlefield situation in
that part of the world whether the
Russians claim it as Russian territory
or not doesn't make any difference to
what's going to go on here in the next
week or two
um
the donbass region and talk about the
other referendums that are taking place
those areas yes I mean in the south in
zaparisia and in cursing the the
demographic makeup is a little bit
different here because these people who
live in these areas are not as as
naturally pro-russian or Russian
speaking as they tended to be in the
donbass even in the donbass there's not
many pro-russians left even if they're
Russian speaking and the Dynamics here
will be different there's a lot of of
Civil Disobedience and assassinations
taking place in Melita Paul in Mario
Paul in these in these areas of Annie
zaponesia itself and of course the
Russians are now under pressure in
cursing in that whole area where you can
see the Shaded area that's the the long
front which the ukrainians have opened
up and it will not be surprising if the
Russians lose a fair bit more in person
the other thing that's interesting is
that Odessa is being repeatedly attacked
now which I think shows another phase in
the war the Russians are now because
their Air Force can't get at it really
and they don't have many Precision
missiles they're starting to use Ukraine
at the Iranian drones these cheap
Shaheed 136 drones as they're called
they're cheap they're easy they're not
very sophisticated but what they do is
they fly around they loiter over a
Target and then they just dive on it and
as it would commits suicide on the
target
they're not specially powerful but they
are a problem and they are now using
them to attack civilian centers and rare
areas behind the lines the ukrainians
now need more air defense they're
beginning to get it now with some of
these systems which the it's an American
Norwegian system called the nasms which
is the national uh
um uh
surface-to-air missile system and these
nasms um and others like it are very
important because this is now a new air
War that's starting between drones
rather than missiles because they're
cheap and plentiful and wet and
ground-based missiles that can start to
shoot them down and we'll see that
developed probably quite a lot in the
coming weeks